that there would have been a lot of
thought a lot of thought given to this
ceremony today by a lot of different
people in order to make sure that it was
pitched just right because there was a
probably a great danger of being pitched
wrong is to think over the last 10 years
and really since the peace process has
been more less consolidated I think we
were looking for it for a centenary that
would attempt to include everybody would
allow us or a complexity that this woman
in the middle of the first world war but
many Irish people has volunteered to
fight in the war but the majority of
those who were killed were civilians of
many many children were killed and that
there's still an argument about it I
mean was it a right thing to do should
we have waited or parts should have
happened so that's why I think all the
radio programs television programs all
the journalism all the historians and
indeed the government and all everyone
involved have attempted to bring a sort
of new narrative to but you know m to
bear on this so we have to look at it
again but it but it doesn't it did
happen it is one of the ways our country
came into being so therefore we do have
to have a day like every other country
does in which we am celebrated and
indeed commemorate and perhaps even
interrogate how Ireland how the Republic
of Ireland came into being okay so there
you have the the parades in the streets
you've got the different national
services marching in time you've got
bands a Cenotaph of sorts what do you
think those few members of that military
council 100 years ago would have made of
this celebration 100 years later
celebrating particularly what they did
and died for you know Dublin's a really
cynical City and people are filled with
irony and jokes it was really amazing
together stamp and is to watch the way
in which example people could
spontaneously applauded the president
have you bent by the way people also you
know responded to the army and the
defence forces with the sort of
reverence with a sort of all I think
that would have really surprised the men
who thought they were they were a
minority of a minority they were a small
group they were dreamers they were poets
some of them they didn't expect to win
and the idea that 100 years later there
would be a state in place
and that that state would be treated by
its citizens as something that was
important and a day you know in
commemoration would would be considered
something you bring children into
witness and the people themselves for
example it was a minute silent in honor
of all the death and people just went
completely choir and and there was a
sense of awe of reverence and maybe
every country needs that you said you
mentioned that a couple of times that
every country needs that day that day of
reminding themselves that they exist
that they were established at some point
and perhaps that establishment was
difficult what makes the Easter Rising
day perhaps different is that
leadership's on the two extremes of your
society on the Republican extreme and on
the unit's extreme still feel a large
amount of antipathy towards this day yes
it's not like France or America or
England or Britain or United Kingdom you
know that this still remains contested
space this idea of who owns Irish
history of what Ireland actually
represents which is why this has to be
done very very carefully it has to be
done with some recognition that for
example there are a million people in
Northern Ireland who feel British as
well as Irish and that we in the south
have to recognize their right to direct
appeal like that and on the other side
indeed we still have the remnants of a
group who think that they can dig they
can the confusion are people M into a
sort of future that nobody wants so that
you know it isn't as though this is a
simple matter that this is a new country
and I think any new country that's come
into into being I mean we weren't a
republic until 1949 and our institutions
are reasonably new and they're not
fragile but they're new and therefore we
don't have a great tradition of this say
the French do at the English do of the
Americans so so it is an important that
it is terribly important to get it right
it's interesting I mean there was a
basked delegation there today as well
and that sort of clarifies that
remembering that that feeling that this
is what this is all about the end of an
occupation and a reminder that the
occupier often underestimates in
misunderstands what it's like to be the
occupied
yeah I saw travelin flags there too I
mean I think any small country that are
a small nation that has hopes to become
a state or any new state that was a
small nation will look to Dublin today
think actually this is an interesting
moment in the history of decolonization
so Island of course 100 years ago deeply
Catholic country organized in a certain
way with a certain type of society now
it's a it's a very modern society its
secular its tolerant its international
so what kind of message should the
people of Ireland take and the people of
Dublin they're standing in the silence
on the roadside what sort of message did
they take from a day like today I think
that em it ends up being citizenship
that this is the country from the
country were proud of and there was so
much talk but at the next hundred years
probably need to build and also there
was an amazing in the afternoon where
more than a thousand will in a choir
sang with the poet poem will do with
written the music our sorry had written
the words and he was there he would
sucked them and he really were as much
about the future as the past and I think
as a writer and I read the libretto for
an oratorio for next week and all the
writers are taking part a lot of the
composers some of the visual artists so
it's a there's still a fence in Ireland
that that that idea of poetry of music
things at the forefront of our sort of
national by ourselves and that I suppose
a very important part of the
commemoration the rising of 2016 was
followed by the best part of 30 years of
internal struggle what you might call
civil war in Ireland which was largely
ignored by the English and it's
certainly not a part of our kind of
education curriculum over here
there's a temptation in England to
regard the goings-on and islands such
celebrations as being quaint given that
Scotland is now also going through a
certain rethink about its role in the
United Kingdom is there anything the UK
or the the UK could learn collectively
or indeed the English
learn from what happened in Ireland in
terms of how it treats Scotland and
perhaps Wales yes there is and island is
so pro-european we were so proud with
Great Britain to join the European Union
in 1973 we have benefited from
membership not only economically but
also psychologically and culturally
being part of Europe Encarta something
much greater our Prime Minister go out
of an equal say in Brussels and so the
key here that Britain would consider
removing itself from the European Union
is for us unimaginable the idea of
European Union represents for us a sort
of modernity as it does for other
countries a sort of time of peace and
it's something that we have Ireland has
worked towards consolidating the arch
defence forces have worked so much
internationally with with United Nations
we care in Ireland about things like the
United Nations and the European Union so
watching watching what's going on across
the water for us is really horrifying I
mean obviously democracy has to work I
mean the till point is saying it doesn't
but I think the majority of Irish people
would view the idea of a British
withdrawal from the from the European
Union I think would be horrified by
Colin Tobin present pleasure talking to
you this afternoon thanks for joining us
here on Sky News